we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] pet peeves wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
[Music]
ah
here we are folks it's a balmy october
day in new york city that the weather is
changing like i put a light jacket on i
did the premature jacket really well you
know when you put a jacket on you're
like i want to wear a jacket but it's
not actually that cold yeah yeah i love
new york in the fall you do the same
thing with the shorts on the other side
of the uh that's right yeah yeah that's
a good point yeah and ejaculation i'm
premature all over
i i threw a jacket on but it's it's kind
of chilly out today it's a little chilly
and uh it'll probably keep dropping but
i got a 1972 george carlin uh some kind
of special he he shot oh dude spin
around show the people it's a nice
jacket look at that
it was a
it was supposed to be a cartoon special
but it never went through cartoon
special yeah no tignotaro did that i
know i know so i don't here's my issue
with cartoon special because i've done
cartoon clips and i've posted them
this guy animated them
people want your facial expressions
that's true yeah it's kind of cool
seeing it as a cartoon but it it doesn't
hold up yeah you get like a 30 seconds
ah that's fun that's what it is yeah
like remember shorty's watching shorties
great idea but it just kind of didn't
didn't didn't fly because you're like i
want patrice you know i get it that it's
a great story and he's a great
storyteller but i want to see him
it's also funny it was patrice and
apollo as babies which
is kind of great because that's it
softens right right their edge that's a
good point so that i like that but yeah
i want i just want to see the stand up
yeah the only thing cool about it is
like i remember one was ted alexandro
doing the gym and the guys look like
pigeons yeah so you can actually see
pigeony guys and that part's fun but but
the stand-up being acted out rarely
works for me
yeah you know what it's like it's like
when people go the book was better and
you go shut up you pretend just queef
but
the stand-up's better you want to see it
in your head you want to let the words
paint it now you're right
you're right let's let's get in this ooh
what do you tell the folks at home what
we're about to break the hymen on here
but to pop the cherry
of this bubble tea we we're going no
alcohol this week because for one thing
i had to drink a lot to survive
springfield missouri so
i hear that how about you do you drink a
lot this weekend yeah i was in rochester
so uh when in rome
you gotta you gotta really hit the sauce
oh that one i think rome was safer than
rochester is right now yeah less
homosexuality
what the hell is going on you got to
pierce it you got to take the sharp end
i know but look how wide this is oh it's
for the balls yeah yeah ah it's like my
ex
all right you suck hard enough you get
the ball
this is i feel like we're in the wild
here i shoot a dart in your neck
all right let's do this so what i don't
even know what a bubble tea is i know i
like it i know it's sweet i know it's
candy but is it healthy is it horrible
is it diabetic it's absolutely not
healthy okay
it's sound it's pure sugar oh jeez great
we could have gotten a milkshake like a
real american this is different
dude damn i can't pop this
[Music]
come on you gotta use a little force
it's like a capri sun do you have any ky
jelly back there
this is the asian capri sun hmm
[Music]
oh my god i got through the syrup at the
bottom whoa good right i mean it's good
but
jesus christ oh sam finished early
when i love myself we had a squirter
oh boy
there you go let me just get my nose in
this real quick
sorry matt
oh yeah are you serious jesus christ
what a god what about peter's gotham
studios
i should have said i'm sorry right
before i did that
all right wow
i mean this is too much this is for
children
oh
that's yummy man i have a watermelon
flavor on the bottom what do you got he
got me green tea
oh no this is pearl milk did we go pearl
milk
did you give me a pearl necklace metal
tell you pearl is the uh the balls are
called pearls oh the balls are pearls
a little necklace yeah there you
go dude that's really good
uh yeah i guess but this is a treat this
is like a what do you think what's a
milkshake oh okay i always thought you
know you hear tea it's like ah it's a
nice asian uh beverage
this is [ __ ] good dude
is this china japan thai what is the
origin of the means of the bubble tea
squid game what are we talking here
did you finish it not yet i'm almost
there i gotta tell you a little
disappointed really mm-hmm man everybody
hates the ending of shows
seinfeld i don't like when it feels like
more is promised
uh-huh like they keep saying they keep
giving you like little morsels and then
you're kind of like all right well where
i need a payoff for some of this yeah i
just felt like
if a show is going to be that violent
i want a little more you know a little
more substance at the end like a message
or a wrap up are you up to are the vips
there yet are the americans they're
coming in the the cop guys that's when
it goes downhill oh really okay
like look there's good moments it's it's
it's look i can't argue with the fact
that it's entertaining as hell yeah it's
violent as [ __ ] i mean i read a book
before bed last night and i slept like a
baby and i was like oh maybe watching
koreans getting executed every night
it's not helping my uh rem cycle yeah
good point good point we're talking shot
to the head just
senseless
you know meaningless killings
that's my issue
it's so meaningless i thought i wanted
like more for the m but yeah i hear you
it's it's kind of like lost this feels
like lost the whole country's in on it
and it was this big thing and it keeps
getting more and more complex and you're
like
i think they're they're laying track
like they're like how do you how are you
gonna figure this out and then before
you know it you're at the end like
we don't know what how do we got here
well apparently the guy who created it
wrote every episode i think that's a
problem sometimes oh really sometimes
you need another set of eyes on that you
know interesting but uh
yeah it's
have you seen him in interviews no he
because i because you watch you're like
this guy's so intelligent then you read
the interviews you're kind of like
maybe he's not i don't know once the
americans came in
it's kind of like uh you're like is this
how the rest of the world sees us
oh [ __ ] i didn't know what americans
came in don't tell me too much oh [ __ ]
all right you didn't hear him on the
phone you're up to that where he's on
the phone speaking english oh i have it
on dubbed so i oh you can't watch it on
dodge i like dub dub design i go dubbed
and subtitles cause i want the words
but uh the americans come up with i mean
they call us round eye which already is
fascinating because to them our eyes are
round and to us they're not isn't that
wild
now the way other people perceive you is
interesting yeah also why isn't that a
slur
round eye yeah
i don't think it's nice i mean i don't
mind it although i said
you know what the problem is i think we
don't see it as a slur because we're
like oh good we have round up
that's what it is that's exactly what it
is yeah we're like you're damn right we
got round eyes we turned we don't we
americans are so full of ourselves that
we it's hard to insult us that's what it
is it's kind of like whitey like hey
crack or honky you're like
and yeah that's the problem well you
can't walk around saying you're the best
all the time and then someone calls you
what you how you see yourself and you're
just like yeah it's great yeah that's a
good point yeah good point
right like
you know people make fun of black
people's hair but nobody really makes
fun of white hair
i feel like i have the brilloy hair you
you're in the middle you're like
on the cusp of white and black yeah i'm
in the middle for sure yeah how about
you're like a little more whitey hair a
little more way but i could i can get a
toe in the jew pool yeah
[Laughter]
the jew pool we'll go we're going to
dangerous territory all right all right
this is squid games yeah it's like
it is
it is entertaining but
the more i watch it i'm like
was i so
i was i seduced by the violence and the
stakes and the colors
yep and is the content not that great
i think that's part of it that's kind of
how i feel i'm like man this looks
amazing
yeah and the brilliance of the show is
it's simplicity it's just like
people scared for their lives how do
they get out of it are they gonna die
are they not gonna die good guy bad guy
it's so simple and i think it's easy to
digest it's kind of like a viral video
where a fat guy falls down the stairs on
roller skates
everybody gets nine hours yeah yeah
exactly except at the end of the roller
skate the spike smashes his head through
you know yeah right dead but
yeah i don't know man i'm i'm kind of
like
you know nice i don't watch it because
there's no diversity
and stop asian hate
the problem with the show yeah that was
my big joke on over the weekend was like
all we talk about is diversity there's
zero and we had a whole month long of
stop asian hate and now it's just like
let's eat popcorn and slaughter them
well they can hate each other oh is that
what we can't hate them that's
interesting yeah
they're allowed to hate
so then that means we don't really care
about their violence or them dying we
just care about who's killing yeah we
the source is the problem interesting
see this is stuff that needs to be
talked about
oh we're talking i love it i love it
dialogue folks
dialogue dubbed the way mark works
but
what what is that what is that oh sorry
for the damn tile on my wallet
so that was that was that was like the
game where he got uh don't tell me i
haven't seen it no you said the
beginning the the where he's throwing
the wallet you throwing the thing to
make it flip oh yeah that's right wow i
forgot about that part yeah well you
forget the parts that are and someone
getting shot in the head there's so much
violence that you forget the new but
that's how you can get away with like
lack of nuance by just just insane
violence yeah and it's also interesting
look we don't have to get too into it
but essentially how we all talk about
like
your words are violent that those jokes
are violent this is violent yeah and no
one cares no one cares there's not one
article going this is my child sees this
he can't sleep sam marilla has to read a
book at night so he can get rem there's
no articles the jokes are they're
characters but
so are we
well yeah on stage kind of stage but
don't you think like on some level
don't you feel like a pit in your
stomach after watching this like yeah
you don't feel good after seeing this no
for sure and you want more you're almost
bloodthirsty yeah you know you need more
but
people like it i think it's also got
that twilight zoney lost thing it taps
into something that that people love
where it's like the unknown and scary
and spooky and weird and you know the
times are weird you know i think uh
times are kooky so we
we kind of relate to this to the guy in
squid games we're like i feel like i'm
trapped in something and i can't say
what i want to say and all this [ __ ] so
maybe there's something to that there's
more i want to talk about but i want you
to finish it all right all right but
it's yeah it's pretty uh
it's pretty crazy it's it's a look
there's a lot i like about the show
there's a lot where i'm just like i just
don't feel that good after watching it's
kind of like it i get the feeling like
watching squid games that i do jacking
off yeah go to like a porno where you're
just like you're like wow wow then the
second you're done you're like ugh
well it is an asian guy getting finished
off
but
you know what you got to do is you got
to cut your squid game with a little ted
lasso that's that's the that's the uh
the black and the white that you need to
make the nice what is it black and tan
or what is that drink called black and
tan yeah yeah how about a
we should have those here new season of
succession do you want oh i forgot the
premiere all right so we're doing these
in advance so the premiere just came out
last night and
it was [ __ ] good was it oh i'm gonna
watch it today that might be the best
show on tv i completely agree watching
it today can't wait totally forgot i was
shifting around going what's going on
today what do i got here lasso morning
show squid game
saints in newark
cause i steal cable so i got every
channel i got every show and i forgot
about succession
this podcast is getting pretty big to
just announce you steel cable wow
come on
you thought you know it's not that bad
of crime yeah yeah it's like stealing
wi-fi you'd never be like i mean i [ __ ]
kids you know yeah exactly i'm not
saying that out loud but um get that
clip by the way
oh
no i don't think so years ago so you saw
the episode where the retreat and the
stand-up comic it's pretty poorly
written yes it's funny when people try
to write stand up like the lines are
like i feel like i'm in a grain silo
being like where's the wi-fi like we
could have punched this up i know but i
remember going in being like i want this
i feel like there's like a hacky comic i
threw a blazer and a t-shirt on went in
beautiful and
they asked for my avails
which means i think my agent was like i
think you might have like what was with
hillary at the time she was like i think
you i think you got this yeah they
answer you around next week oh my god
and that so she was like that i think
they want you and i was like
this is my favorite show get me on and
then and then they went uh nori davis
who was that he was very good oh that's
right he was really good he was good the
lines are rough he makes them work but
they're not
it's weird yeah and he gave a little bit
like he's a cool black guy so it gave it
a little bit of like they would hire
that guy you know because they're like
this cool hip company like a tech
company so that makes sense but damn
that's close
the avails that's like when a girl takes
the bra strap off and then puts it back
on you're like oh you teased this close
so close but uh yeah no that the show is
killer man killer [ __ ] funny can't i
wrote peep show
is that right yes i didn't know that
that's crazy
two of the most different great shows
ever wow
that's almost like a simpsons thing
where you can be incredibly silly and
zany and smart comedy and have a great
show
man i didn't know that
oh dude you know we got to watch matt
can you pull that thing up that i was
talking to you about before the uh
because we're talking about netflix
shows and like how they have to like do
the most obvious [ __ ] for the viewer now
look at this scene watch this scene i
was telling you i saw this on my friend
david angelo's
twitter time uh timeline and it just i
was like this is
this is where it should be forgot your
side sausage right yes thank you
if you'd like anything else we can have
the cook whip up something in the
kitchen no we're good thank you he could
probably do an asian chicken thing if
that sounds good we've got some rice
back there we can have that for you
thank you
suit yourself just trying to be nice the
over-the-top hillbilly waitress from
around here
oregon
america
i do have one question
what's your understanding of chinese
americans oh boy
you call
me is this happening in 2021 in america
the chinese came to this country
oh god this is so forced
those were the only jobs open to them
and we weren't accepted as americans so
much so that congress passed the chinese
exclusion act as well as the gary act
the only u.s law
ever
to prevent naturalization on the basis
of race
it wasn't until world war ii 61 years
later
that we even have the option of becoming
citizens
owning land and marrying a white person
it may surprise you to know i'm as
american as you are as well as my son
despite how we may look to you
so we're going to stick with eggs and
sausage
ass
all right i'm telling you guys you got
it asians are having a moment right now
shouldn't she on marvel squid game crazy
rich asians ronnie chang bubble tea
this it's all been around but
but look that uh that scene man
that is like can you imagine writing
that and think you're like i'll show let
me create a cartoon racist yes and then
write the the most obvious monologue i
know
he just had that in his back pocket i
mean come on you got to get that out of
your diner how familiar are you with
and by the way that you're not connect
you're not changing her mind with that
right right
you know what would change her mind
maybe being like hey uh you know it's
not very nice to say he said let me uh
let me whip out some academic uh let me
let me whip out some some history on you
to just reveal what a dumb waitress you
are i know is this me by the way you
used to make um you used to make shows
where they were like being racist was
like a minor part of a character right
it wasn't the entire character it wasn't
their entire world that's not how
racists are they're not just like jew
asian
jew
jew
jew that's not they you know how they
are they're like jack nicholson in as
good as it gets yes well he'll say
something homophobic or anti-semitic but
he's got other qualities yeah that's how
racism is that's a great point so true
although you just described my set list
[Laughter]
but yeah you're right that's that's true
they don't just come out and they would
probably go in the kitchen go a couple
asians out there we should give them an
egg roll you know that's really
in the words of bill bird racism is
quiet right you know it's not just like
hey what are these black guys doing here
at this bar ah yeah get out of here what
is that i don't even know what the hell
orange chicken in a [ __ ] dining room
i know that's like the laziest racism
i've ever seen yeah that was bad bad
writing they just had to get that spiel
out maybe ted sarandos the ceo is still
under the hot water with chappelle and
he's like we got to get this in
i gotta get all the the
the racism explaining and the you know
the i've learned and all that [ __ ] get
it out there
whoo that was tough man i'm eating here
is that in like 20 years there's gonna
be a scene like that but for trans
people and they're gonna be like in 2021
we were under fire from comedian dave
chappelle but we fought back
[Laughter]
oh that's great what do you serve a
trans person like what does the racist
diner lady say to a trans person
do you want to
i don't even know what what is a a
non-binary meal you know maybe like
something like a butterfly like it
changes oh yeah yeah right i don't know
i don't know
that's a tough one we got this for the
studio whoo
rap and rodney from springfield missouri
man rodney did it all he did cartoons he
did stand up he rapped he did movies he
did tv what couldn't he do
this is this is gonna this is gonna look
good somewhere we'll figure it out yeah
rapping rodney people are sending wall
stuff we got a bunch of joke book look
at that playboy party joke that looks
like [ __ ] we should read some of those
we probably should yeah can we can we do
a quick clip of rap and rodney it's on
youtube it's so good this is rodney
cashing in on in 83 of the i guess rap
was fresh and new and his agent was like
rodney
[Laughter]
you know
put together a few words you do a few
jokes all right oh yeah rapping right
now
i tell you i'm all right now but last we
got some rough shape wow
she's doing his act i played hide and
seek when i was three no respect
why they wouldn't even look for me no
respect
i was an ugly kid i never had fun
[Music]
[Music]
boy how things have changed
[Applause]
i mean you get the point that that is
solid yeah that's pretty great can we do
that with new quick can we get a
technotaro doing mumble wrap
let's
let's keep it going it's this is like
this fellaini and auto tune
mulaney might work with that voice
that's true that's true
man
there you go look it's a bunch of it's a
whole series who sent these in there's a
note up there i should give the guy a
shout out hang on hang on
playboy party jokes
should i read one
yeah oh this is from jared hughes out of
dallas thank you
antique joke books that i thought you
might enjoy for the studio thank you
these aren't like short jokes jared
oh damn i sent jokes in somebody told me
if you sent a joke and a playboy you get
a hundred dollars and in college i wrote
like 20 jokes and sent them all did you
ever get in no i never never wrote back
but that was my big big attempt
uh
that was back in the day when i would go
to open mics watch and not go on because
i was too scared yeah i did that
sometimes yeah
a much married hollywood leading man was
confronted by a pretty brunette at the
premiere of his latest picture don't you
remember me she enthused three years ago
you asked me to marry you oh release of
the blase actor and did you
no that's not bad not bad
and did you that's all right yeah these
are some short ones
the english language is called the
mother tongue because father never gets
a chance to use it
[Laughter]
all right these are just tweets
uh
huh
all right yeah these aren't great we had
a woman down home that was married nine
times she didn't like men but she was
crazy about wedding cake
these aren't great yikes
man being a comic is hard now it's hard
yeah it's uh
yeah this it's all the same joke the
dazzling movie star was applying for a
passport unmarried as the clerk
occasionally answered tree
that's okay it's like a good line like a
noir it's not yeah it's not like a great
like standalone joke all right here we
go drunk walked into a bar crying one of
the other men at the bar asked him what
happened i did a horrible thing sniffled
the drunk just a few hours ago i sold my
wife to someone for a bottle of scotch
oh man that is awful said the other guy
and now she's gone and i want her back
right
you're sorry you sold her because you
realized too late that you love her
right oh no said the drunk i want her
back because i'm thirsty again
it's a long way to go that's not great
oh wow we got a racist uh rendition
there
that's fun
all right all right i feel like this is
bad man has reached an old age where he
can't take yes for an answer
these stinks actually not bad
all right so tell me about uh the the
sin city which is springfield
springfield missouri
good club small city
interesting i mean it's so weird to go
from new york to missouri where you're
like covet is still a thing here and
then you go there and they're like oh
we're not we're keeping the shop open if
grandpa dies he dies oh yeah it's it's
definitely you know
definitely
missouri is a weird
place it's a different world i mean it
takes two flights to get there it's a
tiny airport it's a culture shock i'm
done with these two flights man because
even if you get upgraded you're like
you still gotta you're still smooshed
you're smooshed and you're still like oh
i have to focus like i just landed in
chicago and now i gotta find terminal b
and then oh dude i barely made the
flight back
because we landed at like 2 34
and my and my next flight yesterday was
boarding at 2 30. oh and i'm on the it's
atlanta i'm on the other end of the
airport oh i had to sprint it was like
terminal d and then my next flight was
in terminal t
ah
i'm like
why don't you say z at that point [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] here i was sprinting i
and you're doing that thing where you're
like weaving through people with two
heavy bags
and people on their phone it's like a
[ __ ] zombie video game you're just
weaving
i finally get to the gate and i'm
boarding uh i got lucky i got upgraded
so
i wouldn't have been able to get my bag
on they had to check all the stuff wow
but i so i get on when the last group is
boarding
delta it was like [ __ ] indiana jones
dude i just sweeped under grabbed my hat
it it's always nice when you're because
the boarding process takes a while
because everybody's so fat and then
there's like the guy in the rascal
that's the old lady yeah so it takes a
while and that actually helps you
because you're like oh thank god or you
see the lady arguing at the desk you're
like great occupy them while i run here
it's like when we were young comics you
know when you book like six spots on a
on a saturday in the city and you're
running late to a spot and you look on
who's before you and it's a comic who
always goes along goes long like thank
god this guy doesn't respect the show
i'm gonna make it you know but when
you're on time you hate that guy oh yeah
i hate him because then you don't make
the next spot right but sometimes it
helps but uh yeah man springfield was
cool we definitely um saw nate pargotsy
there the first night he was in the
theater so we great to see him so so
funny man love nate i did his podcast in
nashville
hardest thing i've ever done why well we
i love nate he's the funniest guy he's a
great comic but he's clean
yeah and my whole joke repertoire is
just queef and anal and jews and this
and it's just i sat in that chair just
second guessing everything i say because
i don't want to be myself keep panicking
you're like oh it reminds me of this
woman from nantucket
[Laughter]
yeah exactly and it was it felt like i
was eating dinner when i was 11 with my
friend's parents and you're like yes yes
yes mrs johnson i i'm having a good
school year yeah i'm studying you know
but i mean you must you must have
struggled with those oh that was a mess
did you make did you make [ __ ] up
jokes in front of your friend's parents
i tried not to but you know you you slip
out and plus you know you i had a fart
machine as a kid
you know that whole thing so i was just
like don't touch it took everything i
had
and uh yeah it was tough and you know a
lot of the parents were like mark's a
bad influence really son needs to go to
church and all that [ __ ] yeah yeah damn
well that was louisiana in the 90s
different world but yeah yeah and then i
started skateboarding and a lot of the
parents were like that's
you know what are they pagan punks who
are these kids
that was a weird time what uh man nate
was great to see nate his new materials
killer oh
it's cool man so uh oh you saw this
material yeah i got like the first 30
minutes i had to change hotels so i that
night so
uh i see a pattern i need a nice hotel
you're the hotel guy now well when
you're on the road every week man you
need a decent hotel it was it was run
down and dirty i'm just kind of like i
don't want to be here for three nights
i'm i'm on the road i'm already away
from home every week do they give you
gruff do they go all right diana ross
i'll see you no he didn't it's kind of
i'm like you want to see the room
they're like now we go oh really i don't
think yeah i don't think so
i think i know that hotel yeah that he
puts you in it's not great it's not
great yeah i remember that
and he's a nice guy running
part of kanye west tried to get kanye
west on the ballot that's right so this
is who we're dealing with is a as a club
that says everything about the guy right
there open-minded but still weird oh
yeah
there's such a thing as two open minds
yeah yeah pedophiles
yeah way too open-minded but yeah uh
they might be closed-minded though
um how do you how do you mean because
they don't want to go over
oh
pedophiles do you think they play
blackjack and they get to over 16 and
they
i'm out i'm out they're like hit on 11.
give me another 11.
um but wait so how were the shows shows
were good i did get some of those crowds
that were um i mean the late show
saturday i've never seen a drunker crowd
in weeks and wow i mean i should have
said never because we've been doing this
forever but yeah it's been a while i
mean they were the one woman in the
front row it's gonna be a funny clip uh
she was like playing with her breasts
she's a mom with her kids she was like
heckling me playing with her breasts
like what the hell is wrong with you
damn then she uh then she by the way i
was like she's gonna you know you're
like you're gonna be a problem you're
already groping yourself in the front
row and her daughter's like mom stop
and i'm and i'm teasing her a little and
then
and then toward the end of the show she
goes jew
that's a heckle jew and
and if you can tell the crowds like what
the [ __ ] whoa because they're kind of
like this is
she's wrapping our city here yeah this
is a jew from new york we're not i'm
kind of like laughing i'm just like i
mean this is wow as you said i don't
think this is real racist i know you
just said like i mean no one says that
so i was kind of laughing well i was
like i don't think i think she's
hammered and trying to get attention
this woman hates jews she's clearly i
mean she's doing the boob juggle and
yelling slur not slurs but she's yelling
your uh your group at you that's crazy
yeah i mean if you grow if you're
playing with yourself right before the
slur i'm kind of like eh she's probably
not in the right mind but this is the
way by the way it's not a slur it's just
what i am sure sure but if you're like
black black it looks bad it ain't good
but this is the difference between men
and women you're like look at this
[ __ ] douche and if a guy was playing
with his dick and yelling
chinese chinese i mean that would be a
different that'd be a headline
that'd be the front page of a cnn right
there
but it wouldn't make the paper in
springfield
because it does happen she's the mayor
no she's the met dude it was it was
definitely uh
one of those things yeah and then she
could be going out i'm german i'm german
i was like
whoa i was like this is this is weird a
little threatening yeah i tease i [ __ ]
on her pretty hard it'll make a funny uh
post thank god for the camera because
now you can weaponize not weaponizing
but you how you can take back the power
there take back the night baby yeah
cause at any other time you're in the
middle of nowhere you're the only jew in
100 miles and you're getting called a
jew she's playing with her tits drunk
crowd and you're like i just got to eat
this but now you can capitalize well
it's weird because that we've talked
about it but like you can't tell who's
the jew always sure but i asked like are
there any other jews here there wasn't
any noise i was like all right then
this is going to turn into that scene in
porky's pretty quickly yeah
i did a thing on my netflix which who
knows if they'll keep in but i did a
jewish joke and i go are there any jews
here and one guy went whoo and i went
get em and it killed and uh it's funny
because that is so overtly overtly
racist and bigoted that it's obviously a
joke yeah isn't that weird like if you
go hey so uh hispanic people do this we
were like i don't know but if you go get
that jew kill him they're like ah well
yeah i think that's just how it always
goes when it's like on the line right i
mean that's why if you do an abortion
joke or something and it's just kind of
like
in the middle it doesn't hit but if you
go real hard
it'll hit chuzzleneck is a perfect
example of that he's talking about
dead babies and [ __ ] and everybody's
like this is great
yeah it was springfield it had moments
it was definitely
definitely some crash i'm like they're
[ __ ] drunk yeah they've done a great
job with a club though the club is very
cool the guy really cares he does care
that's really all it comes down to folks
if you think about running a show or
running a comedy club all you need is a
little i was text with mackie over the
weekend he was at the sandman which is
apparently a new club yeah i'm sure he's
supposed to be there in january he loved
it he's like it's great uh
the the guy really gives the [ __ ] that's
all that matters like yes i was in
rochester the guy's got a blazer on he
picked you up yeah mark at bolito great
club great guy you could tell they're
really trying and he's like seating
everybody himself and tearing tickets
and
kicking people out himself like he's
he's in hands-on nice oh yeah he's a
great that's a good club good club big
room yeah it's big baby you did well big
room well it's uh it's a big room
because it's hard to wrangle sometimes
we did pretty well
but the two late shows friday late show
saturday late show where
slug fest i mean one guy i have a video
of it
i'm stealing your thing where i just
film and everything now and this guy
goes i go anybody have any questions i'm
about to get out of here i've kind of
been bombing the whole night getting a
little here a little there a lot of
drunk one guy was sleeping and i go
anywhere one guy goes
can i get emotional and i went ah boy
and the whole crowd loses it and he goes
mark and he starts walking towards the
stage he gets on the stage and i'm like
dude what are you doing and i wasn't
scared because he was like shit-faced he
was blacked out and they just grabbed
him the security just grabbed he's just
a big fan yeah yeah and you're like what
are you doing you've been heckling me
the whole show your girl's on the phone
your friend's sleeping you're like an
inch away from yakking and you're like
finally my moment he comes on stage with
his arms open
and i did a whole thing like dad you got
to stop coming out you know whatever it
was but
it was wild
that's crazy man yeah because if he is a
big fan of yours which clearly he is
that next morning they're gonna be like
dude you hope you don't want to know
what you did i know you rushed the stage
well i'll tag you when the video comes
out fatty because uh
i want you to see it we had another guy
in the front row we're gonna blur the
face so now no well it's it's he walked
up so it's his back so you can't really
see him but he he got manhandled pretty
good by two big big bouncers
but i love that the clubs have been not
every club has been oh i know and
they're like it's again this is why so i
don't have to [ __ ]
deal with this myself i have what is it
about the st i have no fear on that
stage like this guy's coming towards me
he's kind of like a towny guy you know
he's got a raiders hat on and a big i do
have fear on stage this guy was coming
at me i'm like what is he gonna do i
mean i got bouncers here i can just
swing at him or kick him in the balls i
don't know i'm in missouri three times
in the last uh three months so yeah i
i've definitely i've definitely had fear
i've never like am i gonna i make the
wrong abortion joke am i gonna go out
like peter finch in the end of network i
mean
just two dudes stand up
right right um you're mad as hell
i don't know man i i i i know you mean
you do feel invincible sometimes but
also like if you are scared you can't
show her because then the crowd's gonna
get uncomfortable and they're gonna so
like i've definitely been up there and
i'm like i'm a little scared yeah well
you ever seen that clip of dj young fly
no i don't know you familiar with this
guy's work he's an artist this guy is
huge he's just like in the black
scene or whatever you want to call it
the urban scene but he's huge and he's
super funny but he's like he's like a
while and out guy but he's from oh yeah
yeah yeah and this guy there's a video
of him this guy comes on stage and he's
like you sure you want to do this and
the guy's like let's go and he knocks
him out and then goes back to his act
and the guy's just laying there
i'm sure he can find the clip but it was
all over tmz that's the last scene of
the movie the guy he's laying there and
then you see him his hand moving a
little bit yeah that's and that's what
that's going to go to credits there's a
sequel right right but i just love that
this guy's like the real deal and people
what is that thing about comics where
people just like
it's the same with elmo or or mickey
mouse or goofy at the [ __ ] uh
disneyland people just think they can go
up and kick in the ass
and you get those guys that's another
reason i don't do meet and greets
anymore is like you get it's always that
one douche who ruins it for everybody
yeah who like will like like you know
grab your ass or something or like grab
your stomach and you're like what are
you doing yeah
i'm here to be
to meet you guys i know what's wrong
with you and i'm still a person and then
you get those those kind of like bro
douches and you're like the headlock guy
and you're like i'm out yeah well what
are you doing but
i don't know if you can find the the
actual knockout but it should all be on
tape but we'll we'll post that up on uh
we might be oh jim jeffries had the
thing with the guy when he punched him
and it went viral that kind of broke him
i think yeah but look everybody's
physically and emotionally yeah
yeah
um but yeah so this kid in the front row
kept doing you ever had the supportive
heckle but it's still
still throwing you off yeah this kid in
the front row cute kid blonde kid he was
like
where's joe
you know you're like all right man i'm
in the middle of a joke about
slavery or something
uh
at another place what do you mean what
do you mean where
i know it's brutal then he's like how's
the beamer like right in the middle of a
bit you're like ah the bit is ruined now
i'm doing like a chunk on marriage and
it's just ruined well those are like the
pod the podcast fans are different than
the stand-up fans yeah the stand-up fans
kind of know how to be
yeah exactly but then and then you
there's like a crossover but then
there's the podcast people and they're
just like where's fat cat
like and you're like exactly trying to
do a story
and a joke is like a boner like one
phone call from mom and it's gone you
know and that's what these guys do the
phone rings and
yeah you know you go limp but
yeah i got that guy and they threw him
out eventually but he bought a shirt
after and he apologized wow so that is
rare i never had that yeah
so are you doing meet and greets i do a
little bit a little bit of you know i i
wait for like 80 of the crowd to leave
and then i sell shirts
yeah they're mostly
rough oh yeah those are wear you out
more and what's cool is some guys are
like i know you hate this but we
appreciate them like i appreciate that i
hate him i did him for a while and then
i'm just like ugh because if i get
covered then i'm just i i miss it next
weekend no it makes sense i don't want i
don't want
and that's the thing is like the places
you go where they give the least a [ __ ]
about covenant
like i don't you think i want to miss
chicago because [ __ ] springfield is
like we don't give a [ __ ] that makes
sense i'm like well you want to miss
work yeah yeah i don't i like work and i
need it it pays the bills yeah baby i
saw seinfeld in college i was in baton
rouge louisiana and i was at baton rouge
community college seinfeld came to town
the girl i was dating at the time bought
tickets it was the biggest moment of my
life wow it was in some giant theater
this was like
2001. the show had just ended he was the
biggest thing on the planet he was like
elvis
and i remember he came out and i was
like
he ran out on stage went and i remember
like oh my god it hit me like there he
is that's the guy and then he had a
killer act i still remember some of the
bits but at the end he did a q a
and i was too scared and i had nosebleed
seats so i couldn't reach him but one
guy i remember went where's kramer and
he went
sir he's not real
murdered it's like those people at that
height of chappelle show who just like
they're at the show and they're like i'm
rick james [ __ ] and he's just like yeah
dude i mean i think his line was yeah
[ __ ] i wrote it ah
i know
but it just shows like well comedy's
about people so there's people those
drunks don't get that this is about
momentum and timing and like you're just
that doesn't help no no and we can deal
with it but now it's the show's a
different thing exactly how about that
guy he comes up to you later like i'm
the guy who called you a homo and then
you spun it you're welcome you're like
yeah thanks i don't know what they're
expecting would be like hey let's take
this on the road
that was your moment that was your test
and you passed exactly
these little tapioca balls i like the
balls yeah i don't love the tea really
well first of all let's let's break this
down yeah i got a i got a pile of sweet
sugary syrup at the bottom then milk and
then ice
it's a weird mix yeah why not was he
putting milk and ice together yeah
milkshake
yeah you got a point
at least you grind it up a little
cubes of ice floating in my milk but
then with sugar on the bottom it's a
very strange mix well
the show is about embracing new cultures
not breaking them down mark i'm pretty
i'm bracing
you sound like that waitress and uh
and
yeah
the chinese have a proud privilege
heritage i said privilege oh my god i'm
mixing all the words up i'm brain dead
i'm brain dead from this travel
yeah it'll get you yeah
had the uh rochester 48-minute flight
four-hour delay
say like god i'm so close i just want to
get done and then you sit at the airport
for six hours that's brutal yeah but hey
god damn 48 minute flight though i know
i know i had a weird one uh sitting next
to you ever have the thing where what do
they call it the dead head yeah where
there's like another another pilot on
the flight oh you ever seen that
deadhead deadhead is like a grateful
dead oh
dead dead seat it's called something the
dead seat yes it's a great name for on a
flight this is
this became squid games yeah that's what
they're gonna call the window the exit
rover now on this is the dead sea
because if we go down what is that color
a pilot sits on it there's a term for
that
dead
red dead redemption
dead set now [ __ ] maybe it's not even
dead
head
either way i had the pilot another pilot
sitting next to me
and the uh flight attendant came up and
she goes
so uh
we need this seat do you mind taking the
jump seat
and the jump seat is that weird little
flappy labia that flops down off the
wall and you have to sit on it like that
awful yeah i want you to sit there no
not him because they're like you're
we're kind of throwing you a bone here
by giving you this flight you're a pilot
but we got a customer that needs a seat
and she was like do you mind and he goes
i do and i was like
i'm just sitting there like oh god what
happened and she goes well
this person needs a flight and this is
in the procedure like if you know if
someone needs a seat you got to get off
and he was like
uh fine he was like this real [ __ ] kind
of whiny guy but 48 minute flight only
too i know like sucking up he had his
headphones and he's doing like the what
no
i hate that move
and uh she was like eventually she was
like all right sir being a flight
attendant is pretty rough now i know you
could you just have to walk up to people
the whole time you're like show your
mask yes sir i know you're mad but your
mask is here it needs to be here that's
your whole day or then you know you're
it's already a [ __ ] horrible you know
that job must be tough in your body just
always bending over trying to oh yeah i
just think like you know
putting the luggage up
unruly customers all day like you
already did but now it's like because
people people are cranky when they fly
oh yeah i mean you're basically like uh
like tech support but in person
you're dealing with that energy yeah and
being a waiter at the same time yeah
it's always a tough job tough job
yeah i think that's why flight
attendants used to be like hot and nice
and now they're mean and gay
just like
they're cranky
and i don't blame them you know
yeah they used to be like sir do you
want anything like sit your ass down
exactly exactly
i uh yeah i had a cool flight attendant
on the way though i got i got recognized
by him he was oh nice but he go he goes
you're an actor and i think i'm a
comedian he goes the i i noticed the
eyebrows even with the mask
the whole time he's like can i get
anything else i'm like no i'm good but
then you know coffee after coffee i do
like four coffees on those floors
[Music]
they're so weak they're weak they're
weak yeah
man four coffees on a flight three
usually that's impressive
i just man it's
you fly so we fly so much yeah we really
do i guess the dehydrator it's like
that's bad you can dehydrate us from
flying but i know those little waters
aren't doing [ __ ] i would give you a
seltzer this big
that's not doing anything yeah brutal
especially when you're hungover and
you're like just keep the water coming i
need like a gallon of water i drink on
flights if it's like if i'm flying to
the gig the day before i definitely will
have a few drinks
oh yeah you got to take the edge off
that is a good feeling when you're in
first class or delta comfort and just
got that that gin and soda or whatever
the [ __ ] it is is that what you go to
usually i usually do that because it's
bubbly you know i like a scotch or a
whiskey but i want a little bubble i
want to do some wine on one of those
shitty wine it's kind of fun to get
shitty wine drunk you ever gone
international it's free wine free wine
on on delta oh is it yeah that's as many
as you want booze is free yeah
this is actually what my bet is about oh
yeah i'll save the bit for later oh okay
okay
give me give me a wreck oh yeah
hey folks we might be drunk as excited
to welcome our new sponsor good old bowl
and branch baby no one wants to shop for
new sheets in the store you end up
ripping all the packages open just to
feel how stiff they are
and leave a pile of shame behind you for
the store to clean up look i know about
being stiff and then having shame but
bowling branch makes the process simple
by making the softest organic sheets on
the market and they get better with
every wash
look we all like sheets we like a nice
sheet let's be honest no one's washing
them
but they get a little crunchy they get a
little musty and they get a little flaky
after a while so you got to throw them
in there but
nothing better than when you jump in a
bed with nice soft sheets they feel like
an old t-shirt your uncle wore when he
took you down to that weird private room
bowling branch signature sheets comes in
seven colors in all sizes from twin up
to california king and since there's
nothing worse than fitted sheets that
don't fit bowling branch offers 17 inch
deep fitted sheets and labeled size to
help you make your bed like a pro every
time
they only use a hundred percent
sustainable raw materials and as far as
as
as the first
fair trade certified manufacturer of
linen you can feel is about as good
about your bowling branch sheets as they
feel against your skin best of all
bowling brands gives you a
fair price a
30-day risk free trial with free
shipping and returns
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com
get 50 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code drunk at checkout
that's bowl and branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot-com promo code drunk
pass out on these sheets what stand in
the way of achieving your goals figure
it out with better help
better help with therapy for 21st
century for the 21st century this is not
a crisis line this is not self-help
better help is professional therapy all
online it's all remote do it from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
flexible schedule phone or video calls
at your convenience get a good match
they will put you with a licensed
therapist who's right for you i love
therapy i mean oh yeah therapy's changed
my life therapy's taught me that you
know my girlfriend says she's upset with
me to say i understand
instead of uh instead of okay then right
right instead of all right here we go oh
is that what you're supposed to do
fast when you sign up you can start
talking to your therapist in less than
48 hours no waiting around it's
affordable you don't have to be rich to
pay for this and financial aid is
available and now you can send messages
to your therapist anytime they'll go
back to you in between sessions don't
like your person if you want to switch
therapists you can do it anytime for
free they make it easy trust me it helps
to have someone outside your world to
talk to i believe that and true it's
easy to schedule affordable and take a
load off your shoulders over a million
people have taken charge of their mental
health join them mark tell them how to
do it you gotta get on it better help is
a special offer for our listeners visit
betterhelp.com
drunk
visit betterhelp.com
drunk for 10 off your first month
h-e-l-p
dot com slash drunk for 10 off your
first month betterhelp.com drunk sign up
for better help to start living a
happier life
yeah hey hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by honey
you gotta love honey i mean come on you
shop online we all do it you buy shoes
you buy groceries you buy toilet paper
and we've all seen that empty promo code
thing just taunting you and you're like
oh i've only had a promo code i'd get
half off or a percentage something but i
never have one who has that you go to
some
shoe brand you're like ah i could get i
could get a real discount here but i
never have it i always wonder who does
well now honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
discount codes when you're ready to
check out honey automatically applies
the best one instant savings honey has
found its customers over 2 billion clams
in savings supported by over 30 000
stores online buy anything from tech
gaming beer wine you name it
i i saved on uh some sweet kicks
thanks to honey put that code in
got a discount shoes are expensive get a
break tell them how to do it fatty
if you don't have honey
uh you could be straight up missing out
on free savings it's literally free
installs in just a few seconds save some
dough and support this podcast get honey
for free at joinhoney.com
drunk that's join honey dot com slash
drunk and get that honey baby yeah
i want to wreck this and i hope i
haven't done this already but
free
cheap
and easy and no one does it it's it's
seen as a chore
you're gonna say uh looting your local
by the cbs the toilet paper hack is is
taking over the world i'm getting all
nice messages people are sending me
there's nothing from the hotels no the
hotels hate me
by the way the stealing have you been to
a cvs lately it's like they lock up the
tide pods now literally everything's
locked
it's 2am you're like hey can you get the
toothpaste out yeah i'm sorry deodorant
a razor deodorant one is is that because
are people just going in and trying it
on i think hobos just and then get out
of there i assume
i think see i would think that'd be the
one nice thing about being a hobo is you
can just full on let yourself go that's
true yeah
might as well
i don't know so so what what's that
what's this hack
uh well it's gonna sound lackluster but
it's good for you
it's low impact it gets the brain moving
it gets your creativity juices flowing
yeah
take a walk
that's it that's it thank you grandpa
well everybody's like oh how far is it
uh should we drive can we get an uber
if it's a 15-minute walk do yourself a
favor and take it you'll live longer i
know it's new york we're living in new
york everyone's doing this i'm talking
to these queefs out in missouri and des
moines and kansas all right take a walk
walk i love a walk i want 10 000 steps a
day wow
yeah like get up get out walk to the to
the post office walk to the store walk
walk listen to all podcasts and just
walk it's good for you
every time you have to do a phone call
walk and talk smart and uh then you'll
kill the phone it is great
damn low impact i know i i think you're
right i know people run on a treadmill
apparently that's really bad for your
limbs and and joints and whatnot so
walking though low impact but still
burning calories you don't even think
about it
gets the mind going i walk when i do
jokes yeah it's smart when you tell me
that you pace i pace back and forth i
look like a psycho but it helps
interesting
yeah that's
i mean i walk a lot yeah i'm a big
walker especially if i go to another
city i'll walk
i like a good walk find whatever
whatever good coffee shop is in the area
that's my my move yeah you just put it
in the maps and give yourself a goal
sometimes like 30 minutes you're like
but what else am i doing yeah because a
lot of people go i got four hours to
kill i'll watch a show i watch a movie
i'll i'll read but if you just walk
now you're exercising and killing time i
don't know supposed to do a walk in an
audio book there you go
audiobook like kind of like a podcast
and get a coffee and walk get a smoothie
and walk i i think it's bubble tea
bubble tea wildly underrated and i think
people with the pounds would just melt
off people too what was the jared fogle
way aha well he was burning calories at
the uh the playground too but yeah
i'm sure jason kids is a real cardio i'm
sure having to keep 500 feet away from
any school
constantly has you on the move yeah
but
all right what's your wreck i have a few
well first off i have a toast
oh a toast is a weird one too please the
clear coffee mug
i love a clear coffee mug you can see
the color of it
look i love a diner mug i love those
diner mugs but i had a clear coffee mug
recently i love it and it was they put
the milk in and i was like isn't that
nice it's a little classier too somehow
it just looks good all the trashiest
kids in my public school had clear
backpacks and i'm like what are you just
saying mug me you know you got your
beeper in there you got your your phone
in there you got your money in there but
this i get
no it's kind of nice
i love it i think rich people go clear i
i've never owned one i the hotel i was
in had clear coffee mugs that's a great
great observation i love it i love when
you go outside the box here's my wreck
sam's going clear good night unclear
good liner cone line uh uh famous red
blue raincoat did he ever go clear oh
remember that
the from that song no i don't know
great tune uh he's a good writer great
writer so uh
my book
started a book speaking of
it's really good it's called uh
a drink before the war
it's a dennis lehane book you guys
probably know who he is he's uh
a lot of his stuff got turned into
movies oh really gone baby gone mystic
river oh wow
he might have done the departed too i
mean he's done so any boston yeah crime
thing he did okay
all right he's great um
pretty dark pretty brutal dark fun
feels like a classic noir but uh it's
really good and as i said man you read
before bed you just sleep better it
really does help
literally watching
a korean massacre every night before bed
yeah wondering why i'm like my heart's
racing i know right also just staring at
a screen we stare at screens all day you
gotta shut the screens off that's
another wreck shut off the [ __ ]
screen here here
you got that right not now you got to
finish the episode but at some point
yeah when you see that you ever see your
screen time and you want to kill
yourself i can't look i don't i don't
want to know it's embarrassing it's
brutal it's like looking at your porn
search history like after you jerk off
you're like i gotta get my life together
you're gonna be on your deathbed and the
time is gonna flash before your eyes and
it's gonna be you just doing this oh god
you're right i ever talk about that meme
i saw where was an old guy on his
deathbed and he goes oh [ __ ] he goes uh
uh my one regret
spending more time on twitter
i wish i had done that oh you know like
nobody's gonna think that but we spend
so much time on all this [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] my name i don't want that one
anyway all right it's gone give me
wrapping rodney
rapping rodney
sorry uh meta knight or whoever that was
yeah i like that one better anyway all
right what about um
all right so that's good wreck good
wreck screen time down reading up and
get yourself a clear cup
uh yeah i gotta i gotta get one
i like it i think it's a great move
clear cup is fun it's also fun if you're
like you know
if you're not like i'm a coffee drinker
but if you like tea it's kind of fun to
do to see the color of the tea i think i
agree i agree and i'll give you another
uh wreck that i just thought of now that
you mentioned your uh clear cup is
candles
i know i sound like some holistic
guzzler i love them i love them too they
don't do anything i mean they smell
better but they just add something like
this guy hangover candles dude he sent
us stuff before i love this stuff great
they smell great they look cool you get
them in like a lacroix canyon yes yes i
love that guy yeah yeah hangover candle
shout out that guy's great and i'll tell
you another thing man you get older you
start to appreciate [ __ ] like that 15
year old me i'd be like whoa oh you're
gonna get a candle now i'm like you know
what like i like getting socks as a gift
good socks yeah a nice candle yeah i'm a
[ __ ] boring old guy now you got that
get some
you're gonna have the worst christmas
socks candles and clear cups
sounds great now party time
when you get to be an adult you can buy
[ __ ] that you want that's true so so
these little things are actually really
nice i'll tell you another coffee cup i
really like you can pull it up on matt
it's
it's like the new york coffee cup but
it's a it's a glass i have that cup i
have two of them i love this the greek
uh blue and white yeah i have that's it
i love that aren't those fun hillary got
me those same oh okay well she's
re-gifting
[ __ ] it's funny when someone gets you
a gift and you're like it's cause i'm a
new yorker and she's like yes yeah she's
just giving him everybody i know that is
such a nice touch i love i love those
cups
good something about a good coffee mug
that's really nice it's funny how people
are like that was a shitty paper cup but
when you go back to it and make it a
real cup it's like clever
you know it's kind of like lobster
lobster was like poor people food
peasant food yeah and then now it's like
it's just rebranding you can rebrand
anything you know they got these old
this was an old mill factory but we kept
the lights and the ceiling the same and
the floor but now it's a laser tag
vintage yeah dude richard jenny remember
that joke he had about
such a great line every every lobster in
the tank
you know at the restaurant they all that
look like any word from the governor
talk about underrated recommend richard
james jenny's great he's got some
platypus man a steaming pile of me
amazing yeah he was a great comic
his specials were like
they were like actually special it felt
like he was performing he was sweating
and every bit was punched out and had a
big ending and like a tada
classic comic classic killed himself
and regretted it apparently like he was
alive while he shot himself in the mouth
and i think he didn't die instantly and
he was regretting it whoa
yeah
that's wild
i mean it sounds obvious if you shoot
yourself in the face and you're still
alive you're probably gonna be like this
was not a good
idea right you're not you're not going
to be like you know what good choice
yeah uh no but richard jenny one of the
best uh comics yeah yeah
what yeah the mask is the every watch
the mask it's not that good nah it's not
great i mean harry's incredible carrie's
incredible
yeah and so and the cast is good it's
richard jenny cameron diaz her first
movie i think she fought hard to get in
that too she was she was a looker so hot
in that yeah peter green from the usual
suspects the bad guy oh yeah great bad
guy good character actor yeah also uh
peter roger
from animal house in the sopranos
huh which one was he who the [ __ ] i'm
talking about peter roger you know him
oh ben stein was in it wow whatever
happened to caiman oh yeah
boone yeah
and he's uh in the sopranos that's right
that's right he's the cop
or fbi or one of those no he's like a
politician isn't he oh no not no he's
like some sort of like government oh
okay
wow whatever happened to cameron diaz
give her a good [ __ ] she's gonna win
away
no she's in a ton
that was
that was quick and easy
no lingering season a lot dude i don't
know lately though oh once you do shrek
three you're you do three shreks you're
good to go you're good to go how about
no dude she was great in uh being john
malkovich oh so good that's a great
movie great so weird spike jones man
what a turn around that guy there's that
um skateboard director
i guess she's known a ton lately that's
what i'm saying she was this huge
leading lady like a-list lady and then
gone women getting older in hollywood
ain't easy
where are we right
i don't think it's easy
interesting retired there you go i knew
something was up
she [ __ ] timberlake and that was it
you got a peeve
yeah
what do i have what do you got
all right now this one
might
might make me seem like a douche but uh
it gets annoying
how about this guy
uh
ah [ __ ] i wrote it down but i know i
can't remember how i meant to say it i
got a couple peeves so i'm gonna throw
them all at you all right um
options but don't care i don't know what
that means but how about this one when
you go all right guys we got
reservations at the restaurant we're all
going to the restaurant at 8 30 and we
all go great we're out let's go to the
bar have a drink okay it's only eight
we'll kill some time at the bar and then
you're at the bar you're going all right
it's 8 24 we should probably start
walking over and they're like yeah yeah
we should and then we move like 10 feet
and then you just keep talking and
you're like all right guys
it's 8 27 we should probably get out the
door and go to the right yeah yeah
you're right now we moved by the door
now we're on the sidewalk talking i'm
like
god
what is that well
you want to keep things moving yeah and
and yeah people that are not
they're not with the plan that annoys me
yeah and we just keep kind of
like
orbiting that way they're on their own
time and you're on your time you're
probably trying to get out of there too
right oh well also yeah but i'm like we
got reservations in four minutes like
let's let's go to the hostess is this
this happened recently yeah but i feel
like this happens all the time with your
girlfriend no i was with a group oh yeah
but i feel like this happens all the
time when you're like okay
everybody everybody and you're like all
right let's start moseying and people
just can't leave or can't get going like
we just can't go put the drink down and
walk you have to like everybody good
well that guy went to the bathroom we'll
wait for him okay it's like ah
there is a thing someone when people
aren't on the same time as you would
annoy if there's not like
yeah that that bugs me yeah yeah that's
weird then we went on the sidewalk now
we're talking out there i'm like why
can't we just walk and talk we can keep
going
but
so of course we were like 10 minutes
late to the reservation but you're like
all right whatever this is actually
hilarious
you know we're scratching uh you know
what we're running out of pee is when
you're like and then i was 10 minutes
late to a restaurant but it's it's the
principal i'm with you dude anytime
like my girlfriend did this recently
she'll do that we're watching a movie
and she got up and just like went to the
bathroom i assume she's just peeing and
coming back she's brushing her teeth
she's doing her skincare i'm like we got
a movie on yeah just sitting here right
maybe didn't love love the movie maybe i
guess so i mean if you're if you're
gonna if you can brush your teeth
throughout a movie you're not that
invested i don't know i think she's like
i thought we were winding down i was
like i was not informed on this plan
yeah i'm in movie mode i'm in movie mode
i'll tell you mm-hmm i don't really have
a peep i guess that was i wrote down i
think i did it last week was the one
when people say you can do better didn't
i do that oh yeah we drink on this pod
hate to do better no he can do better
how about this one when people get angry
at you but it's not your fault like what
this is this might be a girlfriend
specific or a wife thing but like
so girlfriend is like or fiance is like
hey when are you landing tomorrow i'm
like well i'll be landing at uh 2 30 and
i'll probably be at the house by 2 or
305 with you know coming from newark and
she's like great i'll have everything
set up we're going to do this we're
going to do that i'm like great
hey sorry the flight's delayed ah you're
killing me what happened to our plan i'm
like
yeah i know i want to do the plan too
i'm in cincinnati yeah i'm happy i know
like i'm not flying this thing it's not
my airport
yeah the flight delay is tough but she's
like oh you're ruining the damn like me
what did i do
i'm stuck i'm in the airport at least
you're at home with your feet up
meanwhile you're hungover in a hotel bed
you overslept for the flight it got
delayed why won't you trust me no
there's not a dead hooker here
well i've had it with your questioning
your line of questioning is offensive
yeah what is this an interrogation come
on but no it's just like
you know you go all right we're going to
the restaurant at eight all right we get
to the restaurant the bling burned down
ah you ruined the night i'm like i
didn't know it burned i didn't burn it
what am i an arsonist
so that [ __ ] bugs me when it's not your
fault but you somehow get in trouble we
travel every week so we do get like you
know
we we still get annoyed by delays like
i'm used to them now so i'm not as
annoyed but like yesterday when i was
running for the flame like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] dude i know
i'm hurting my neck just because i'm
like sprinting with two heavy bags yeah
and then when you get to the destination
no one's like and you're like man i have
barely made the flight they're like oh
yeah whatever okay so you're in the
ceiling you're like ah not only
yeah nobody cares yeah that's the hard
part you want to [ __ ] you want to
dive in you want the [ __ ] you want
the flight attendant to go
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's great
safe you made it
yeah even they seem annoyed like i want
a high five on the way in by the lady
but she's like
barely made it you're like i'm here
aren't i yeah we we get spoiled with
status because we fly every week but
then you see what it's like to be in
that last boarding group and you're like
this fight this takes me back oh yeah
this used to be every week every week
yeah sometimes if it's a short flight
i'm like yeah i'll take 29 d i don't
give a [ __ ] and then the problem with
the 29d is waiting for to get out people
are just [ __ ] worthless they're
worthless i'm like how come when i got
my bag it took four seconds i went and
i'm done you're like
here's something behind you they're like
let me see
yeah what is that they're like looking
at it like hmm i know yeah they turn to
someone they make a comment you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah i had like a very
strong independent woman i was in the uh
the window seat and she comes in and
she's like i'm supposed to be in the
window but i don't care i'll take the
aisle and i was like well and she's like
fine oh you can have the window but i'll
take the aisle i don't care i'm like
okay well would you rather have the
aisle in the window i would that's what
i was trying to say but she was like no
no no it's okay you take the window and
i'm like
okay she just sat down and put her
earbuds and i was like wow i didn't get
a word in
so that was tough damn now you guys are
dating
yeah she was kind of hot and
glossy yeah
women are bossy love bossy yeah you're
not supposed to say bossy what are you
supposed to say but women don't like
bossy why not i think it's like
if men were bossy it's it's like leaders
i call men bossy i do too but i'm bossy
that'll there's all these dumb rules
that's annoying also but someone told
you not to be bossy kind of bossy
good point that's why they don't want
you to say it because they are that yeah
we're in this weird place where like
gender is a construct but it's also like
as a woman so like being a woman or a
man is like this important thing
but it's also like gender's not real
it's fluid it's weird because we're like
saying two things
and
which one is true like which one do you
go with
you know it's like
gender isn't real it's fluid the future
is female like well how could it be
female if there's no gender yeah and
then you start saying that [ __ ] and
people kill you
these are just jokes that are bombing
you're like a feminist retreat you're
like what's the deal
yeah what's the deal this is the shame
are you kidding me i'm in hot water but
isn't hot water good i love a hot tub
what's the deal with that
hot water sounds like a jacuzzi
yeah who doesn't like a jacuzzi i love a
jacuzzi love it who is jacuzzi jacuzzis
likes kleenex or or uh or what it was
sharpie jacuzzi sister to yakuza i'll
tell you
asians are big right now
but jacuzzi is a guy
yeah i think right i think so yeah but
we call it oh that's a jacuzzi but that
might not be a great it's a it's a fun
sounding order it's a great word jacuzzi
that is great it sounds nice yeah i
think a jacuzzi is it italian or asian
let's get on it is it tony jacuzzi or
hey jacuzzi yeah or is it uh like
hiroshima katashi jacuzzi you know like
which one is it
which one is it matt
yeah
figure that one out jacuzzi brand
headquarters
california
oh see why did you watch it just be like
a white woman this is like that seinfeld
where she's like i thought you i thought
you were asian oh yeah
the rhinoceros
she's not asian and they're all
disappointed yeah
italy
okay see that could have gone either way
yeah it's funny the italians always brag
about their food but jacuzzi's big
jacuzzi's big
that's up there with uh
benihana that's a guy is it yeah benny
han is a guy
betty hanukkah that's kind of fun that
had a moment that kind of came and went
that was a fad well the problem is that
it's very like uh sticky and then you
can do that with like korean food that's
actually really good
oh yeah the barbecue yeah griddle yeah i
love a korean barbecue dude oh so good
comes with like eight sides and apps i
[ __ ] love that i know what a fun
outing too it's like it's not just
dinner where they bring you food you're
watching it you're felt feeling it
you're smelling it the smoke it's a
great moment how about the uh do you
ever watch on tick tock they'll do the
um whoa
penny honda found her face is 12 12 to
18 months in jail whoa what do you do
hit a guy with a shrimp
no one's gonna [ __ ] with him in prison
he'll take two shivs and start chopping
them up right right exactly
what did he do you know his son is that
dj famous dj benihana
[Laughter]
no he's like this i forgot his name he's
a asian guy with long hair
huge yeah if you saw him you'd know him
admits to insider trading damn cool just
footage from being like benahan is going
to have a big month
did did madoff die steve aoki that's his
name oh yeah he is big he's huge look up
his uh net worth
he uh i met him on jim and sam he was a
guest cool guy cool guy and he has this
he can sleep anywhere because he's so
busy that he knows how to sleep like on
a plane
in a in a bus or or like he can just
take a nap in a green room like i can't
i can sleep on a plane but he can just
go in a green room be like all right i
have two hours
and he's fully refreshed like he's one
of those guys it's a gift 95 mil not too
shabby for a dj
i don't get it
skill this job do you ever watch on like
uh on tick tock they'll do those like
those people just going like is this
restaurant overrated or underrated
and it's just a guy being like you know
like they're flipping the meat at the
korean barbecue place and they're like
properly rated and you're like three
million views like what the hell i know
right i don't get anything on tick tock
how about this guy with the salt
yeah you see sope yeah why is this guy a
celebrity what has he done because
people are dumb and people share [ __ ]
like that it's like we're saying with
the viral it's just it's whatever is
accessible and easy to digest i get it
he's some weirdo doing this [ __ ] salt's
coming off his elbow yeah i got dandruff
how about this this is my thing it's not
going to do as well that's true
do a joke all right
got a couple ideas kicking around
all right tell me if this is anything
so i feel like america is kind of
divided culture war yada yada we all
know it we all talk about it fox news
versus cnn right verse
it almost feels like the government
is our parents
and your dad's a republican your mom's a
liberal and this this the civilians are
the kids
and they've all they've forgotten about
us they're just trying to get each other
because they're divorced yeah and uh you
know i got all these jokes like mom mom
i need lunch money and she's like will
you shut up i'm trying to cancel your
father and you're like but what about
the citizens you know and uh i'm like
dad dad um
mom says i i shouldn't go i shouldn't
have a gun and dad's like well she tried
to abort you you know you did the
liberal versus that hit
i haven't tried it yet but i like the
idea of uh the dad and the mom being
divorced and they don't care about us
they're just worried about it hurting
each other at this point you know you
watch the news it's like they're just
trying to sleep i think
they're just trying to get our attention
oh
that's good because it's like they're
just saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] to get our
attention so it's like so you talk to
your dad be like do you see what your
mom is trying she's trying to let other
people into the family
that's great you want a bigger family
you want to live with this mexican kid
huh yeah that's good you know and then
and then the mom is like your father uh
you know it's just got to go back and
forth he's like you should see what he's
he doesn't care about you yeah he
doesn't care exactly that's good
all right
your father's talking to a russian
family he cares about you
that's maybe the angle i like that that
little tweak of they're trying to get
you they're trying to win you over yeah
which is also more realistic for divorce
yeah
yeah that's good and i get to attack
both sides
and you know everybody everybody wins
yeah that's good because
doesn't it feel like everybody pretends
like we care about this group and what
about this like republicans are like
these people are killing babies and then
lefties are like hey we need to let the
muslims in or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and
it just feels like everybody just wants
it their way no one's listening to each
other right like i was at a gym i used
to be a member of the rec center it's
still closed by the way i love it yeah
it's brutal that's been i know
it's 80 bucks a year
the only problem is you're in there with
a couple of moocs and riff-raff but
i would uh i would go in there and every
day i went to the gym there was this old
guy who would play salsa music at like
full blast on a boom box
everybody hated him but he was old and
but it's also like 80 bucks a year
exactly what are you going to complain
exactly is you get what you pay for so i
would just turn my headphones up and i'm
like ah [ __ ]
you know that [ __ ] and then this one day
this young kid comes in and he's blaring
hip-hop and they're just competing
speakers and the old guy's going what
are you doing and the young guy's going
what are you doing yeah and he's like
well i want to play my music and he's
like well i want to play mine and they
couldn't understand that they were both
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and that's kind of
what i'm trying to that's like a
microcosm of america sure sure but i
don't know how to make that funny but
the old guy's like well i was here first
oh
yeah yeah that's true but he's like i
pay your taxes or you know maybe the
young guy's like i pay the bills the
future i'm the future yeah
yeah something like um it is interesting
like uh i mean those rec centers though
they really are oh you get some [ __ ]
shows yeah yeah it really is you get
what you pay for i mean it's like being
on a greyhound versus first class yeah
you know greyhound is like fist fights
and chicken coops and guy playing video
games at full volume
i do too
you ever wanna go go to the lower east
side watch the uh like the chinatown one
the guys who play ping pong they're
unbelievable yeah i would just sit and
watch
yeah they're like this is really our
asian uh celebration yes asian sensation
there's something there all right what
do you got i wrote down let me find it
it was about flying um
we don't have enough comedian jokes
about uh air travel
mm-hmm
what about dogs and cats they're
different
what's the deal with it's uh that's no
picnic but aren't picnics good i thought
we like picnics all right so
everyone uh i'm on delta in there like
everyone thank you for being a part of
the delta family and i was like family
like we're not a family when something
goes wrong with my family i don't tell
them
right there's no complaint line there's
no yeah i don't i don't complain to my
mom i yeah if delta with my family i
wouldn't say hey you guys messed up i
would be like you know what i'm going to
keep that in here ah that's good also
when i drink
on delta i can get like four drinks
they're never like four
drinks that's great um something about
like if delta
if delta [ __ ] up i'm not just like look
delta's limited you know this is all
they can give me yeah i don't know
there's something here that's good oh
there's a lot here delta doesn't shame
you
delta never says uh you missed your
flight we're a little disappointed yeah
we're disappointed in you we thought
you'd make it yeah
yeah more of you i don't know no that's
great
also
you can upgrade can't upgrade family
can't upgrade fans wouldn't that be nice
yeah i have a joke about that though
right now i do a joke while i do that i
would do i used to do a bit about like
uh
you get a new phone you can upgrade
you're like that'd be cool if when you
your grandpa died you could do that like
he's just like your grandpa but he
doesn't say the n word and you're like
ah that is better like did he still say
oriental they're like we couldn't fix
everything that was a joke
maybe that's how old it was it was the
grandpa five not the grandpa 5s oh
that's good that's how old that joke was
right iphone 5. wow yeah but it still
still holds up still works it would
still head if i do it but uh yeah could
be something too about how like the more
money you make with delta the better
they treat you yeah wouldn't that be
weird if your mom was like oh sam
yeah is that a new sweater yeah
here's an extra plate here's more dinner
like you're not like gold with mom
you know mom you're just on board mom's
on board all day long you can't go
platinum no status with airline there's
no status with
with parents
there's a lot here this is great
i like the shaming thing yeah you know
your mom's like four drinks huh wow
yeah there's something there i tried it
in springfield and it did not work
really
someone miles maybe
yeah uh you can't you can't throw money
at your mom
huh
yeah we'll crack it
what if there's a connection joke
when you're my mom don't connect or
something ah [ __ ] i'll crack it i'll
crack it we should we should get some pa
we should get a patreon out too i like
it though i like it i don't trust
springfield i think there's something
here make sure to email us at we might
be drunk pod at gmail.com with your you
know videos with your uh peeves hell
yeah with your rest with your jokes
drinks anything uh well there's no mom
app there's no mom i can't go to all my
app be like ah my mom's mad at me hold
on let me [ __ ] yeah you don't tweet at
your mom
all right sorry uh yeah that's something
there the abs the app is fun mom app uh
make sure to see us on the road i got
phoenix this weekend san francisco
charlotte uh north carolina
miami improv uh
[ __ ]
all over that [ __ ] dude hell yeah oh
dallas
samurail.com
shows
is that hyenas no uh i'm banned from
hyenas oh that's right yeah oh we gotta
hear that story on tomorrow
all right all right all right i'm at
portland we're adding shows laugh boston
come on out don't get too drunk beantown
break california vancouver in canada
uh
new orleans hometown hero royal oak
michigan atlanta bucket theater
milwaukee
improv
come on out eventually chicago i hear
that too soder loved it so uh thanks for
everybody coming out thanks for writing
thanks for tweeting thanks for sharing
some guys sent us some badass art today
that that one you posted that looked so
good i loved it so uh yeah send gifts
we'll put you on the wall these joke
books are killer we love you we might be
drunk
happy halloween next week
very exciting next week ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're backlogging episodes because we're
both on the road guys sorry we just
revealed the uh trick there
we love you
keep listening
tell your friends see you soon thank you
gotham studios and matt we love you all
right praise allah
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you